[Music]
hi i'm stephanie wong a developer
advocate at google cloud now at first
you might think i started my career as a
software engineer or developer but i
didn't start with a computer science
degree
actually i started out with a different
kind of cs degree communication studies
i thought i was going to go into the
entertainment industry
if you're like me and you don't have a
traditional computer science degree or
tech background here are some tips and
guidance to go from a non-tech career to
cloud
all right step one listen
first and foremost before you dive into
taking boot camps and becoming a
self-taught developer take the time to
think about what part of cloud computing
excites you and notice any industry
trends like cyber security mlai
kubernetes or serverless technologies
now you might not know much about these
topics but do the research about the
qualifications for each because this is
going to inform your next step where to
invest your skills
some of my favorite resources i continue
to use even today include the google
cloud blog and podcast screaming in the
cloud podcast cloud wars podcast tech
lead journal podcast
this youtube channel and there's many
more
the key here is keeping your ear to the
ground for major trends pushing
industries forward it's less about which
cloud provider to learn but more about
asking yourself if you enjoy learning
about information systems data analytics
apis or cyber security the goal is to
find that magical bit of overlap between
the technologies that are market movers
and your interests
when i was in college i got to learn
about tech in my minor and analyzed
social media data my first job out of
school was related to analytics but as i
saw cloud computing start to explode i
totally shifted my focus to start
learning about cloud databases and
infrastructure
this is what led to me getting my
eventual job at google cloud
also coming from a non-tech background
doesn't mean becoming a software
engineer is your only path in the cloud
there are so many roles in cloud and new
ones popping up every day
you have customer or sales engineers
developer relations which is what i do
solutions architects ux ui designers and
researchers product managers and more
you might not realize it but your
non-tech background can actually give
you an advantage for your career in
cloud
for example my communications background
actually let me stand out in deveral
once i honed my technical skills over
some years my ability to distill complex
topics and present on them publicly
became a big value add
if you have sales experience for example
it sets you up beautifully to become a
sales engineer once you gain some
experience with cloud technologies sales
engineers work closely with sales reps
with a common goal to sell cloud tech to
clients
if you do have coding experience but you
don't want to be a pure software
engineer it can actually give you an
edge when it comes to other technical
roles in cloud like solutions architects
developer advocates product managers and
customer engineers my communications
background gave me that ability to
translate complex topics into simple and
persuasive narratives i also worked as a
computer lab consultant so i could
troubleshoot systems issues my former
experience set me up to become a sales
engineer in tech because i could listen
to customer pain points and translate
cloud technologies to address gaps in
their technical environments
i then became a cloud implementation
engineer where i could use my lab
experience to help onboard cloud clients
and use my deductive reasoning to
troubleshoot their issues
your own unique skill stack is really
your own swiss army knife of skills that
you can leverage in your next cloud job
step two learn
once you have that settled it's time to
go all in on learning about the cloud
and applying that knowledge
as someone without tech experience your
biggest weakness is your lack of
experience you need to start building a
portfolio of work to show that you have
the necessary skills to learn quickly
apply that knowledge and grow in a
quickly evolving space
there are many ways about this that are
free in fact forest brazil from our
first episode of this series has created
a cloud resume challenge to give you an
effective way to learn a breadth of
cloud concepts on each major cloud
provider and apply that knowledge
hands-on by building and hosting your
resume in the cloud
by the end of it not only do you learn
fundamental concepts about cloud
services like cloud storage cloud
functions and terraform but you have a
tangible piece of work that shows
employers that you can succeed in the
job
and hopefully this can inform where you
want to specialize because
specialization can also help you focus
your attention to a particular area in
cloud like let's say devops tooling and
narrow your first job search
bootcamps and crash courses like udemy
and certifications are another great way
to learn from a blank slate
google cloud offers a number of
certifications like the associate cloud
engineer and you can attend a full
course to prepare for the exam by
heading to our courses created on
pluralsight or with coursera
but
heed my warning about both bootcamps and
certs they give you a great
understanding of cloud concepts and
products but they are not a replacement
for experience
as they say knowledge without action is
futile
if you are aiming for a technical role
you must apply that knowledge by
building something tangible whether that
is your own web app in the cloud
contributing to an open source project
or participating in an online data
science challenge
and remember you also can get 300 of
google cloud credits
for all roles it's also great to produce
your own content about cloud like blogs
or videos covering your own projects or
cloud case studies to set yourself apart
as a thought leader
check out my teammate pukola who created
a youtube channel teaching devs how to
build a spotify playlist generator and
so much more her channel even helped her
get a job here at google cloud
your online presence is your resume
these days don't let your lack of
experience stop you from building your
own body of work
step 3 connect
as someone coming from outside of tech
it's crucial for you to build your
network joining a live course with class
members is one way to meet others but
there are a number of free online and
in-person meetups for the cloud industry
for example on meetup.com there are
several meetups for google cloud
enthusiasts in cities around the world
that host monthly events i have
personally seen people learn network and
get jobs through these meetups google
cloud innovators is a program you can
also join to network with other google
cloud champions and get access to
exclusive events and leverage social
media to post your work and network
but keep in mind that cold intros asking
for jobs or mentors doesn't cut it be
sure to partake in conversations online
about cloud computing meet others
organically and share your
well-researched thoughts and questions
before asking for mentorship or help
remember your career isn't just about
the work you do but about the
relationships that you build
step number four
break into cloud
let's say you've got your first
interviewing cloud
this is where the real test comes in
because your interviewer's initial
perception of your lack of experience in
cloud can be changed by your ability to
sell yourself and your grit your passion
to learn and your adaptability
make sure that you are applying to the
roles that fit your current skill set
and where you want to head and come
prepared by practicing questions coding
interviews and presentations far in
advance hello leetcode
this is where a coach or mentor can
really come in handy as they have
invaluable insight on both the interview
and the role
so in conclusion listen
learn connect and break
look getting your first job post boot
camp after becoming a self-taught
developer or deciding on a career change
is really hard
but it will get so much better and
easier once you gain experience and
expand your network so don't give up
i am living proof that those with
interdisciplinary and non-traditional
backgrounds can break into and flourish
in cloud
so best of luck in your own journey like
and subscribe to our channel we'll be
back with more advice on how you can
crack your cloud career